bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi
la violence des orages la nuit dernière
dans la banlieue de lyon où il est tombé
près d'un mètre de grêle gros débat
également dans la région parisienne où
300 personnes ont été évacuées
la campagne présidentielle en corse
nicolas sarkozy fait l'éloge de la
culture insulaire et dénonce la lâcheté
des poseurs de bombe à paris ségolène
royal réunis les artistes qui
participeront à son meeting de charléty
et indique que dominique strauss kahn
pourrait être un très bon premier
ministre
par ailleurs à 48 heures du grand face à
face les deux candidats se préparent
pour leur duel télévisé
dernier sujet d'opposition à distance
l'héritage de mai 68 dénoncé hier avec
virulence par le président de l'ump dans
le pas-de-calais quatre personnes sont
toujours hospitalisés pour des fractures
de vertèbres après l'accident d'un
manège selon les premiers éléments de
l'enquète il aurait été causé par la
rupture d'une pièce mécanique en turquie
le premier ministre du parti islamiste
modéré en appel à l'unité nationale mais
ne cède pas après les manifestations
monstres d'hier
la présidentielle n'est donc pas remise
en cause la bourse a plongé de 4%
enfin quatre mois et puis s'en va fabien
barthez confiant qu'il quitte le fc
nantes après une altercation avec des
supporters samedi dernier on commence
donc avec les va-et-vient surprenant de
la météo après les grandes chaleurs du
mois d'avril les habitants de la région
lyonnaise ont eu la surprise dans
certains endroits de voir tomber hier
soir près d'un mètre de grêle les
chasse-neige ont même dû intervenir sur
place denis sébastien jean claude martin
jusqu'à un mètre de glace accumulée en à
peine une heure
l'image a de quoi frapper après les
records de chaleur de ces derniers jours
des grêlons charriés par l'eau
envahissant les sous-sols et parfois les
rez-de-chaussée des maisons ce matin
encore les habitants avaient du mal à se
remettre d'une nuit éprouvante bien
quitter bourg sous sol j'avais deux lola
ici
tout d'un coup le congélateur un gros
congélateur se renverse sur moi j'ai
failli tomber notre congélateur un plus
petit s'est renversée aussi j'ai eu peur
aux plus de portes n'ont plus rien mais
porte du garage et les questions mêmes
voitures c'est ce qui nous fait depuis
un paysage quasiment hivernale l'orage a
éclaté en début de soirée hier une grêle
danse et continue qui a bouché la
canalisation et empêcher l'eau de
s'écouler
cet après midi encore le nettoyage
battait son plein et la glace malgré la
chaleur n'avait toujours pas disparu du
paysage cm sur toutes les propriétés
autre conséquence les arbres fruitiers
cinq exploitations sur la commune les
feuilles et les fruits ont été comme
broyé par la grêle pour cet
arboriculteur c'est toute la récolte qui
est perdu il ya 100% de dégâts avec la
une punk qui a été complètement coupée
en deux l'arbre a cédé le bois a lâché
là vous vous jetez des petits grêlons
qui font cinq ou dix grammes sur des
pommes qui sont en pleine maturité en
plein grossissement et là c'est du
martelage l'amour j'ai jamais vu ça
un orage spectaculaire qui restera dans
la mémoire locale
on n'est pas habitué à voir la grêle ici
en avril et surtout pas en paraît
quantité aucune victime à déplorer
heureusement sauf peut-être cette carpe
qui n'a pas été épargné par le
ruissellement et a été retrouvée bien
loin de son étant d'origine
le ciel est il devenu fou bonsoir
laurent romejko vous avez une
explication
oui c'est violent c'est impressionnant
alors pour que la grêle se forment en
fait il faut qu'ils aient une importante
différence de température entre l'air
chaud et humide qui est au sol et puis
l'air beaucoup plus frais qui est en
altitude alors la gouttelette d'eau qui
s'évapore monde dans le nuage le
cumulonimbus elle se glace à son sommet
et le cristal de glace lui retombe sans
toucher le sol
ils les taux nous aussitôt aspiré dans
le nuage il fait comme ça plusieurs
allers-retours plusieurs trajets en
grossissant forcément à chaque fois
lorsqu'il est suffisamment lourd il
retombe au sol parfois des grêlons
jusqu'à de l'ordre de 5 cm de diamètre
c'est exceptionnel mais ça arrive
en tout cas c'est ce qui provoque la
violence de ce type de phénomène c'est
ce qui s'est passé hier soir dans le
rhône 25° c'était la température hier
suffisamment chaude
toutes les conditions étaient réunies
plus la proximité du relief les monts du
lyonnais inconvenant favoriser la
convection a favorisé la violence de
evènement ces cellules en plus était
quasi stationnaire ce qui fait que cette
grêle s'est déversée vraiment
géographiquement sur un seul et même
endroit elle s'est peu déplacé alors ce
type d'événement n'est pas rare mais
c'est très tôt dans la saison
c'est sans doute le résultat de ce mois
d'avril est extrêmement doux
exceptionnellement doux puisqu'on a eu
les chiffres pour ce mois d'avril on est
7 degrés au dessus des températures
habituelles sur toutes les régions du
quart nord-est
on y reviendra dans un instant merci
laurent et vous on vous retrouve bien
sûr à la fin du journal des orages aussi
un peu partout en france avec d'autres
conséquences notamment en région
parisienne
en moins de deux heures des pluies
torrentielles ont fait déborder les
cours d'eau dans plusieurs villes de
l'essonne richard binet emmanuel bec
comme si le ciel leur est tombé sur la
tête dès les premières heures du jour
les habitants de villiers le bâcle
tentait de rejoindre leurs habitations
pour mesurer l'ampleur des dégâts
on a lutté avec des balais pour
repousser pendant deux heures et demie
parce qu'il ya le sait le chant fait qui
s'est déversé dans le jardin et puis ça
a gagné devant et donc ça monte ça monte
ça monte r on a mis des parfums va
essayer de
balayés
il est avec des sources puis l'eau a
envahi les maisons à priori à part le
living le reste c'est sauver les canapés
on échoue mais bon y'a du boulot - selon
les témoignages tout s'est passé très
vite
des pluies torrentielles s'abattaient
hier sur plusieurs communes de l'essonne
la mérantaise la rivière locale sort de
son lit en quelques heures
le niveau de l'eau atteint par endroit
plus de 2 m envoyez-le à hauteur de 1
300 personnes sont alors évacués ce
matin une centaine de sapeurs pompiers
tentaient d' assécher les quartiers
inondés ont pensé le pompage autour des
pavillons pour le diminuer la quantité
d'eau qui est stocké ici la renvoyer
vers plus bas vers la marocaine à
gif-sur-yvette les eaux de la mérantaise
qui avaient envahi les rues commerçantes
du village se retire peu à plat cet
après midi les sapeurs pompiers
tentaient d' assainir le centre ville au
plus vite de nouveaux orages sont
attendus demain ont parlé de contraste
tout à l'heure avec laurent romejko
météo france a fait ses comptes
effectivement sur l'ensemble du pays le
mois d'avril aura connu une moyenne de
températures supérieures de 4 degrés
supérieur donc aux normales saisonnières
7° donc sur le nord-est comme on disait
c'est un record depuis 1950
françoise mavic philippe turpault
la mer méditerranée serait tel le seul
endroit où le thermos ça n'est pas
complètement déréglé sur terre le soleil
donne à chacun l'impression de passer au
grip sur toutes les régions françaises
on a compté en avril environ 11 heures
d'ensoleillement par jour
pratiquement le double de la normale le
thermomètre a vu rouge 24° à caen 28 à
bourges 26 à roissy en région parisienne
du jeune ait vu depuis l'apparition des
premières stations météo à la fin du 19e
siècle qui est surtout remarquable c les
températures de l'après midi puisque
dans le quart nord-est de l'île de
france au nord et au nord-est on a un
excédent qui atteint 7 degrés serait
temps partir de l'après midi c'est à
dire qu'au mois d'avril on a eu des
températures qu'on aurait dû avoir au
mois de juin avec parfois des
températures jusqu'à 12 degrés au dessus
d'un mois d'avril habituel la végétation
a mis le turbo
mais les chants peu sont secs comme de
la poussière on en vient à la campagne
présidentielle pas de temps mort je vous
le disais pour les candidats nicolas
sarkozy était en corse aujourd'hui où il
a réalisé un gros score au premier tour
il a rendu hommage aux traditions et à
la culture de l'île mais on retiendra
surtout sa charge contre les poseurs de
bombes sur place
alix bouilhaguet mathieu berden la
course
ce devait être la dernière carte postale
de la campagne mais la pluie a contrarié
les projets annulés le pique nique au
bord de l'eau tous se sont pressés dans
la petite cinémathèque pour voir nicolas
sarkozy c'est un des seuls notre
ministre d'aller ailleurs qui est venu
plusieurs fois en corse et tout ce que
les promesses qu'il avait prêté les a
tenues qu'ils représentent la loi le
droit il faut voter sarkozy parce que
c'est une seule personne qui peut
nous sortir nous on est dans la salle
pleine à craquer c'est l'embouteillage
aujourd'hui celui des t-shirts tandis
que les stars locales sauf le public
qu'une chose c'est que son président a
autorité c'est le mot clé de cette
visite en évoquant l'assassinât du
préfet erignac
nicolas sarkozy réaffirme la fermeté
vis-à-vis des poseurs de bombes
est-ce que c'est courageux de mettre une
cagoule est-ce que c'est courageux
d'aller faire sauter la nuit venue
est-ce que c'est courageux de mettre
trois balles dans la nuque d'un homme
seul qui rejoint sa femme à un concert
dans les rues d'ajaccio
ceux qui ont fait ça sont des lâches
nicolas sarkozy est arrivé hier soir sur
l'île avec ses conseillers politiques
dont leurs alliés socialistes eric
besson au menu une séance de travail sur
les derniers jours de la campagne
avec ce déplacement en corse nicolas
sarkozy continue de dérouler sa
stratégie de l'entre-deux-tours
rassembler au maximum et afficher
clairement l'image d'un président
protecteur
ségolène royal elle prépare son grand
meeting du stade charléty prévu demain à
paris elle réunissait autour d'elle
certains des artistes qui mettront
l'ambiance elle aussi a déjà en tête le
débat qui aura lieu après demain
quel vilain bertry sans le bras
pour ces artistes là ce devra être
l'anti bercy le contraire du show à
l'américaine organisé hier au tour de
nicolas sarkozy c'est assez rock'n roll
à monter parce que tout ça ça se fait
donc un peu à l'arraché on va essayer de
faire un bon gros spectacle à son pépère
en guise de woodstock le stade charléty
pour la bande annonce est aujourd'hui lé
chanteur georges moustaki et cali sait
combien ce dimanche prochain c'est vital
pour nous on peut on peut réellement
basculer vers quelque chose qui on a le
risque qui nous plaît pas et demain
entre autres stars renault yannick noah
et bénabar chanteront pour la candidate
ce lundi au quartier général de ségolène
royal c'est jour de visite
josé bové vient en personne apporté son
soutien pendant qu'en coulisses les
proches préparent la grande affaire de
la semaine
le duel avec nicolas sarkozy qui par
définition toute ma vie politique a été
faite de dialogue et de débat je n'en ai
fui
aucun c'est bien c'est la conception
même que j'ai de la vie politique et
dans l'argumentaire de ce débat en tout
cas de cette fin de campagne
le joker ce pourrait être lui dominique
strauss kahn ferait un très bon premier
ministre dit aujourd'hui ségolène royal
l'intéressé acquiesce tranquillement je
veux rassembler toutes nos forces et je
crois que c'est ce que ces lois est en
train de faire le rassemblement c'est un
élément important pour la prochaine
présidente de la république
dsk distribuant des tracts pour son
ancien rival imaginaire impensable
aujourd'hui indispensable dans l'équipe
royal pour espérer l'emporter
depuis hier un nouveau sujet a fait
irruption dans la campagne il s'agit de
l'héritage de mai 68 et hier nicolas
sarkozy l'a vigoureusement dénoncé cet
héritage la gauche aujourd'hui s'en
inquiètent ségolène royal elle même a
défendu les avancées engendré selon elle
par le mouvement
alexandre kara tristan le braz mai 68
serait-il responsable de tous les
errements
c'est en tout cas le point de vue de
nicolas sarkozy hier bercy
il a consacré pas moins de vingt minutes
à la condamnation de cette révolte d'il
ya 40 ans les héritiers de mai 68 avait
imposé l'idée que tout ce ballet
il n'y avait donc désormais aucune
différence entre le bien et le mal
d'ailleurs il y avait plus de valeur
plus tard archi il avait réussi il n'y
avait plus rien du tout et eux mêmes
s'étaient pas grand chose daniel
cohn-bendit meneurs du mouvement
étudiant surnommé alors dany le rouge
dénonce la charge du candidat de l'ump
ira tous ces gens vous n'avez plus de
valeur vous n'avez pas de valeur vous
n'avez pas le moral ce n'est pas vrai et
je crois que c'est les insulter et après
il va dire je suis victime pourquoi on
met est on le hait pas mais on dit il
dit n'importe quoi
libération de la femme accords de
grenelle négocié entre autres par un
certain jacques chirac ségolène royal
oppose à nicolas sarkozy les avancées de
mai 68 puis qui découvre en fin de
campagne les ouvriers avec les caméras
ils devraient se souvenir que mai 68
c'est aussi 11 millions de grévistes qui
ont obtenu les accords de grenelle qui
ont obtenu la section syndicale
d'entreprise qui ont obtenu la
revalorisation de leurs salaires
pour certains chercheurs il ya bien une
face obscure de mai 68
autant pas contesté que les dimensions
disons de légèreté de d'irresponsabilité
de remise en cause de la valeur travail
qui se sont répandus dans notre pays
trouve sans aucun doute son point de
cristallisation dans ce roman historique
en mai 68 ni ségolène royal ni nicolas
sarkozy n'était dans la rue pour cause
il avait alors 15 et 14 heures et chacun
a maintenant en tête le grand rendez
vous de la semaine le duel télévisé de
mercredi soir
un premier élément a été présenté
aujourd'hui la table et le décor du
débat et les nuques diane richard ni
grand huit ni nouvelle galaxie pour le
match d'après demain
le décorateur s'est inspiré d'une arène
sportive
j'aime beaucoup de sade de franz et le
toit du stade de france et que sarah nos
mains peut inspirer pour la table quatre
éléments de plexiglas translucide pas
question de voir les gens des candidats
du blanc du noir sauf sur les trois
écrans géants ou l'image reste à
déterminer
à gauche ségolène royal à droite nicolas
sarkozy
ainsi en a décidé le tirage au sort en
face côte à côte
arlette chabot et patrick poivre d'arvor
seuls les chaises ne sont pas encore
choisi le maintien est bon si les
chaises sont bonnes si on glisse pas
avec le pantalon si voilà on tient
compte vers la taille des candidats
évidemment deux cars régie 17 caméras
dont 5 de secours
techniquement rien ne peut empêcher le
déroulement du débat rouge antennes
hormis les quatre protagonistes le
plateau évident des loges réservé aux
invités des candidats deux heures de
débat un temps de parole égal que le
téléspectateur pourra suivre sur cet
écran est une contrainte pour le
réalisateur il ya une contrainte
une contrainte qui a été imposé par les
candidats et validé par le csa c'est
qu'ils ont demandé à ce qu'ils aient pas
de fournes coupe du candidat qui ne
parlent pas c'est à dire que pendant
qu'un candidat parle on n'a pas le droit
de montrer l'autre je ne mets pas droit
les candidats viendront demain chacun à
leur tour découvrir l'horloge le décor
la table et les chaises prise de contact
unique avant le grand débat mercredi
soir
difficile de mesurer l'impact de ce
débat sur les intentions de vote l'idée
généralement admise est que ce face à
face ne fait sans doute pas gagner une
élection mais qu'il peut la faire perdre
nous avons voulu savoir quels souvenirs
particuliers en garde et les
journalistes qui les ont animés dans le
passé ahmed tazir bruno girodon une
poignée de main pour une première
1974 c'est la première fois qu'un débat
est organisé entre les deux finalistes
d'une présidentielle
giscard mitterrand à leurs côtés deux
journalistes au rôle strictement minimum
si on française comme vous nous l'avez
demandé nous nous interdirons
naturellement de poser quelques
questions que ce soit à l'un d'entre
vous n'avez pas monsieur mitterrand le
monopole du coeur avantage giscard c'est
ans plus tard avec les mêmes
protagonistes avantage
errant et vous avez tendance à peu à
reprendre leur faim d'il ya sept ans
l'homme du passé c'est quand même
ennuyeux que dans l'intervalle vous
soyez devenu vous l'homme du passif
cette fois les journalistes ont le droit
de poser des questions ils viennent de
la radio pas de la télévision jugé trop
partial à l'époque françois mitterrand
faisait une liste et valéry giscard
d'estaing choisissez sur cette liste les
personnes qu'ils voulaient et il a dit
je choisis par ordre alphabétique et par
le fait des tic le premier était jean
boissonnat et les deuxièmes avec un c
sept ans plus tard françois mitterrand
retrouve jacques chirac son premier
ministre
je ne suis pas le premier ministre et
vous n'êtes pas le principal de la
république
nous sommes deux candidats vous nous
permettrez donc de vous appeler monsieur
me taire mais vous avez tout à fait
raison mais c'est le premier ministre ou
pire on parlait on voyait chirac qui
avait un mouvement nerveux des genoux y
regarder si fij a gardé ses notes salées
téléspectateurs ne le voyais pas quand
chirac parlait les téléspectateurs ne
veuille pas mitterrand mais nous on
voyait mitterrand une fois de temps en
temps de regarder une note
mais il avait les deux mains sur la
table était très calme très posé et il
regardait chirac en permanence avec un
air assez sarcastique et l'air de se
moquer de lui en 95 entre chirac et
jospin s'est carrément plus courtois
en somme je voudrais dire badinant bien
sûr mais avec un fond de sérieux qui
vont mieux cinq ans avec jospin que sept
ans avec jacques chirac
ça serait bien long ça serait bien lors
qu'il est même passé des choses assez
assez bizarre c'est que jospin avait
assez gros pas mal grossi pendant la
campagne et il avait sorti le costume
est en fait il rentrait pas dans le
pantalon ce qu'il a fait le débat dans
un d'inde avec un costume dépareillés il
avait même une cravate qui faisait des
reflets ce qui fait qu'à un moment
claude chirac a proposé un jeu sans fin
une des cravates de chirac
au fond il est pas il est pas rentré
dans le studio la maison de la radio
j'ose pas avec l'idée d'en découdre en
2002 pas de débat pour cause de le pen
au second tour
rendez vous donc mercredi 21h sur france
2 pour le face à face royal sarkozy
on l'a beaucoup dit rarement une
élection aura passionné autant les
français on s'attend encore pour ce
deuxième tour à une forte participation
mais s'agira-t-il d'un vote d'adhésion à
un candidat ou de refus de l'autre
candidat
la campagne telle que vous la vivez à
thiais reporte à gilles marine et lionel
langlade dans ce bar de thiais comme
ailleurs en ville il y allait décider ce
qu'ils savent quel bulletin
ils vont glisser dans l'urne
vous avez changé
et vous me suivre dans les chevilles
valérie landes en demie et puis il ya
les autres
certains ne cachant pas qu'ils iront
voter en reculant et je peux pas voter
blanc ou nul ça sert strictement à rien
c'est est comptabilisé quelque part on
fait l'avons celui après tout essayé
pendant cinq ans verra bien mais
je vais voter quand même un peu les yeux
fermés devant le centre commercial le
lieu le plus animé cet après midi
nombreux sont ceux qui affirment avoir
choisi sans pour autant s'enthousiasmer
loin de là je vais choisir pour le moyen
terme
voilà c'est prêt de la conviction c'est
pas la conviction mais bon je dirais que
on va dire que j'ai une situation
professionnelle qui fait qu' il y en a
un des deux qui est le moins pire que
l'autre je dis pas comme certains entre
la teste et je ne sais quoi non quand
même pas mais moi franchement je vais te
pour elle mais en consultant
j'arrive pas bien comprendre ce qui se
passe en fait des votes de raison qu'ils
seront parfois incertain jusqu'au
dernier instant
et vous pensez vous pouvez prendre vos
décisions je pense mais je ne suis pas
sûr non plus donc ça peut être un
décision ce que dernier moment jusqu'à
l'isoloir
ça peut être ça peut être la décision
jusqu'à l'isoloir effectivement moment
crucial pour les indécis en attendant
l'isoloir
le duel télévisé mercredi entre les deux
candidats et l'information sur la
présidentielle continue sur france 2
émission spéciale de mots croisés ce
soir avec trois face à face sur
l'économie la politique étrangère et les
questions de société à suivre au tour
d'yves qu'elle vit bien sûr à partir de
23h10 dans le pas de calais quatre
personnes sont toujours hospitalisées ce
soir après l'accident d'un manège hier
elle souffre de fractures des vertèbres
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
la rupture d'une pièce mécanique serait
en cause
d'autres vérifications sont en cours les
accidents il faut le savoir sont rares
mais ils marquent les esprits car les
manèges sont de plus en plus
impressionnants les forains eux
insistent sur la rigueur des contrôles
karine comazzi amené louis brèche on
connaissait le saut à l'élastique en
matière de sensations fortes il ya
maintenant en allemagne
la version horizontale le mach 1 ou
comment se prendre pour un oiseau à 120
km/heure
mais cette année le clou de la foire du
trône et le candidat
propulsion et descentes à la vitesse
d'un avion de chasse
seul le public est insouciant car pour
ouvrir le propriétaire lui soumis une
fois par an un contrôle technique très
strict
on nous demande de mettre le malaise
dans des mauvaises conditions c'est à
dire d'un seul coup de le bloquer s'il
ya quelque chose qui va pas donc il faut
que ça soit mais pour les forains les
vrais contrôles ce sont eux qui les font
contrairement aux parcs d'attraction ou
le manège est immobile pendant plusieurs
années
les forains qui passe de ville en ville
montent et démontent foulée deux mois
mais c'est quand même nous vous reverrez
prix les manèges le jour avant de partir
et maintenant nous sommes gérés quand
même par l'électronique donc des gains
défaut vie va apparaître le malade va se
mettre en défaut et enfin la recherche
la cause chez prévente is l'un des trois
organismes de vérifications techniques
on estime que l'électronique rend les
manèges plus sûres
sur les treize accidents survenus l'an
passé aucun n'a eu lieu sur ces nouveaux
manèges halte relais fortes sensations
de quoi rassurer les 50 millions de
visiteurs qui fréquentent chaque année
les foires de france
économie un changement de culture et de
comportement en perspective pour les
contrôleurs de la sncf la compagnie
pourrait leur demander pour mieux servir
les voyageurs de se muer en chef de
train au programme salué les voyageurs à
leur arrivée sur le quai parler
plusieurs langues et se mettre à leur
service
une expérimentation est en cours sur la
ligne paris strasbourg bruno timsit eric
de l'agneau christian leur contrôleur
sncf heureux de travailler en binôme
voici son équipière brita rayman e
contrôleuse allemande deux uniformes
pour un duo franco-allemand ce sera la
règle à bord du tgv est
leur mission d'ici au mois de juin
maîtriser la langue de l'autre
cela commence par des exercices
pratiques et mesdames et messieurs dans
le cadre de la nouvelle unité en place
des services d'accompagnement pour
l'instant encore un petit peu difficile
et c'est difficile pour les deux
et pour les y aider orage ô désespoir ô
vieillesse ennemie
les cheminots ont reçu des cours de
théâtre objectif un meilleur accueil du
client bonjour contre les layettes
j'évoquais oublié le temps où le
contrôleur n'était là que pour contrôler
les billets aujourd'hui ils sont
relookés par le couturier christian
lacroix la sncf copie ses concurrentes
les compagnies aériennes est ce que
réussissent très bien les compagnies
aériennes c'est donner de la
considération à leurs voyageurs et sur
cette considération où on veut faire des
progrès et on veut prendre les
meilleures pratiques des tours
les contrôleurs du tgv est ont jusqu'au
10 juin pour devenir totalement bilingue
plus qu'un mois et vous pourrez viser la
quinzaine du commerce équitable s'est
ouverte dans toute la france ce week-end
il s'agit d'en faire la promotion c'est
devenu une tendance qui s'affirme
regardais ces chiffres en cinq ans on
est passé de 12 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires à 160 millions
d'euros
on s'interroge souvent sur ce que
recouvre ce label de commerce équitable
et bien en voici un exemple
il s'agit de sacs fabriqués en afrique
du sud que vous verrez peut-être bientôt
en france c'est le dossier de cette
édition elle est signée jenny briffa
laurent des bois
c'est un labyrinthe où vivent un million
de personnes kayelitsha le plus grand
bidonville du cap
n'importe qui s'y perdrait pas elle
nicole marie rech en connaît chaque
recoin
il y a dix ans elle est venue en
vacances ici elle n'est jamais repartie
touché par la détresse des femmes elle a
décidé de les aider grâce au commerce
équitable
il fait chaud à une coopérative de file
des quatre partis que j'ai créée et elle
fabrique des shoppings bad en toile de
jute biodégradables ces ateliers
nicole marie ne les dirige plus les
couturières sont leur propre chef dans
ces coopératives elle qui n'avait rien
avant ni emploi ni argent pour nous être
chef
c'est vraiment incroyable parce que ça
nous prouve que nous avons le pouvoir de
faire tout ce que nous voulons nicole
marie a monté une société qui
commercialise les sacs
elles achètent la totalité de la
production volontairement au double du
prix du marché pour assurer un salaire
décent aux couturières pour autant pas
question de charité qu'elle tarn à 35
kilomètres du bidonville au siège de sa
société
nicole marie supervise la nouvelle
collection vous dis mais qu'est ce que
tu pourrais le faire en verre il faut
des modèles originaux pour que le client
accepte de les payer davantage son
objectif un chiffre d'affaires de 800
mille euros ce jour là dans le plus
grand centre commercial d'afrique elle a
rendez vous avec son principal client
la première chaîne de supermarchés du
pays les fans suivent depuis que nous
travaillons ensemble nous avons constaté
que votre projet est bien implanté au
sein de la communauté noire
et comme vos produits participent au
commerce équitable nous avons décidé de
vous donner ce label pour votre
participation à l'émancipation
économique et moi l'an dernier 40 mille
sacs du township ont été achetés à
travers le pays essentiellement par des
blancs l'argent des beaux quartiers
réinjecter directement dans le township
de quoi révolutionner la vie de paul
hayes l'une des plus ancienne couturière
avec ses filles elles vivent à seringue
dans cette cabane sans eau courante
je sais qu'à y prenez vous votre douche
et hier ici j'ai cette petite bassila
jeu mais de l'eau dedans et je me lave
ici pourtant paul elle fait figure de
privilégié grâce à son travail elle a pu
acheter tout l'électroménager dont elle
rêvait et surtout inscrire ses quatre
enfants à l'école
mais avant c'était très difficile pour
moi je n'avais même pas de quoi acheter
des chaussures pour qui les enfants
aillent à l'école
tout était très difficile avec leurs 400
euros par mois
les couturières font des envieux
certaines ont déjà été cambriolée et
aujourd'hui ce sont des banquiers qui
viennent jusque dans le township leur
ouvrir leurs premiers comptes
on croyait que la banque était réservée
aux blancs bâti non mais non je peux le
dire maintenant ce n'est pas que pour
les blancs c'est pour tout le monde
tous ceux qui veulent garder leur argent
en sécurité
elles sont
le commerce équitable a transformé la
vie de ces femmes tout comme l ont
bouleversé l'existence de nicole marie
lasson donner un sens à ma vie elles ont
donné j'ai pu m'intégrer et puis et puis
donné ce que j'avais à donner dire ce
que j'avais à dire à travers à travers
ses produits que l'on sort à travers
tout ce design à travers toute cette
créativité
elles me font elles me faillite et
quatre nouveaux ateliers vont ouvrir
cette année avec un objectif mieux
s'implanter sur le marché français
pour l'instant seuls trois boutiques à
paris distribuer les sacs de ces femmes
de khayelitsha en bref on y serait la
commission d' enquête sur le conflit
israélo libanais de l'été dernier a
rendu ses conclusions
le premier ministre israélien ehud
olmert et le ministre de la défense amir
peretz ans sont considérés comme les
principaux responsables car ils ont
commis je cite des erreurs sévère selon
cette commission
dans la foulée ou d'olmert a reçu le
soutien des états unis la maison blanche
a fait savoir qu'il est essentiel
ce sont ces termes aux efforts de paix
laïcité contre islamisme la crise se
poursuit en turquie au lendemain des
manifestations monstres le premier
ministre erdogan du parti islamiste a
lancé un appel à l'unité nationale
mais s'il ne cède pas l'élection aura
bien lieu et vous le savez c'est l'un de
ses ministres nombre également de ce
même parti islamiste qui devrait être
élu
la crise a entraîné la chute de la
bourse aujourd'hui -4% pour bien
comprendre voici l'un des sujets sur
lesquels se cristallisent l'affrontement
les lycées religieux envoyés spéciaux
dorothée cochard régis mater
des pépinières d'islamistes c'est ainsi
que les qualifie les défenseurs de la
laïcité les imams pratique les lycées
religieux ici contrairement à la loi
turque
la plupart des jeunes filles portent le
voile enfants de récréation ben la
moitié des heures d'enseignement sont
consacrés au courant
ce matin ses cours de lecture y compris
pour les jeunes filles vous alors quoi
apprendre aux filles
à lire en public le courant ne seront
pas iman h m2 hors dom secours lecture
du coran ça n'est pas réservé aux imams
les fouilles aussi doivent pouvoir venir
d'art ou de voir correctement chez elles
ou dans leur famille et le directeur ont
fait pour suivre la visite et nous
explique que l'autre moitié des cours
est strictement identique à n'importe
quel autre lycée bien que religieux les
imam hatip sont financés et contrôlée
par l'état un système mis en place par
atatürk le fondateur de la république
c'est la garantie pour cet état laïque
de garder la mainmise sur l'enseignement
de l'islam en turquie professeurs sont
formés par les ministères de l'éducation
quran tous les imams à tiques sont sous
contrôle du ministère
c'est pourquoi il n'y a pas de danger de
dérive islamiste
ces lycées ne serait donc pas des
pépinières d'islamistes mais
l'université reste quasi inaccessible
pour eux c'est la loi qui le veut une
loi qui a pour but d'empêcher les
lycéens les plus religieux d'accéder à
des postes clés plus tard au parti
islamiste au pouvoir a tenté de changer
cette loi est de favoriser l'accès à
l'université de ces lycéens issus de
formations religieuses bien le projet a
suscité un tel tollé dans l'opinion
publique que le gouvernement a dû
retirer ce projet de loi ce qui montre
que en tout cas aujourd'hui
les turcs sont encore très attachés
alors laïcité en bref sachez que le
prince harry ira bien en irak décision
prise par le chef d'état major de
l'armée de terre britannique l'héritier
du trône
l'un des héritiers
du trône deuxième dans l'ordre de
succession devrait rester six mois sur
place et diriger une unité de blindés de
12 hommes
aucune date précise n'a été communiquée
en chine une campagne de civisme a
commencé pour préparer la population à
accueillir les jeux olympiques
il s'agit de modifier certaines
habitudes qui pourrait choquer les
étrangers sur place pascal golomer
sylvain yum
il est une fâcheuse habitude dont les
chinois ont du mal à se défaire c'est le
crachat en pleine rue accompagné souvent
d'un raclements de gorge fort peu
élégant cercle crachoir qu'on voyait il
n'y a encore pas si longtemps aux côtés
des grands dirigeants du pays a disparu
désormais des salons officiels et dans
la rue la tradition demeure
alors ce matin sur la place tiananmen
les autorités de pékin ont lancé
l'offensive avec un bataillon de
bénévoles et d'étudiants prêts à les
éduquer le cracheur invétéré lui
apprendre le sens de la propreté et du
savoir vivent à moins de 500 jours des
jeux olympiques
il n'y a pas de petites bêtes à la
jemmerais que dans mon pays et le
civisme des habitants soit à la hauteur
de notre développement économique et qui
se rapproche de la moyenne
les grands pays et seront jugés sur la
place de la gare les équipes commandos
sont passés à l'action
plutôt que de faire de longs discours
mieux vaut distribué l'équipement
indispensable au crashers potentiel
c'est plus efficace
démonstration
vous pouvez cracher dans le mouchoir
douchez et ensuite mettre le mot shoah
dans le plastique avant de le jeter à la
poubelle
la première fois on donne un mouchoir
mais la deuxième on donne une amende de
5 ans tu aimes 5 euros le crachat
personne n'a été pris en flagrant délit
aujourd'hui à la gare centrale
mais empêcher un pékinois de cracher
c'est un peu comme empêcher un parisien
de rallye au volant autant dire que la
tâche s'annonce ardue pour les autorités
qui prennent affaire très au sérieux car
rien ne doit venir gâcher la belle image
de la chine et des chinois qu'elle
compte bien présenter pour ces jeux
olympiques retour en france avec la
foire de paris ce soir les dernières
tendances en matière de mobilier des
cheminées à roulettes ou des meubles
barbecue visite signé françois jullien
pied noir frédéric basket sacrilège ou
tendance une commode louis 15 par
viollet de couleur rouge fluo jaune
flashy bleu pétant cette année couleur
et baillet tartine les meubles même les
plus nobles le côté austère de tous les
meubles qui sont en merisier merisier
noyer chêne des couleurs très foncée
austère les gens en ont marre
aujourd'hui ils veulent personnaliser
leur intérieur ils veulent donner une
petite note d'originalité plus de
couleurs d'accord mais surtout - de plus
en plus le prix du mètre carré augmente
dans les villes plus le meuble devient
convertis
on a deux camps mais les gens continuent
à avoir deux enfants donc pour les
poires les loger pour pouvoir laisser
remplir recevoir des amis
bonsoir démérité donc on fait vraiment
des pièces qui vont passer de bureaux à
chambre en un clin d'oeil
en regardant devrait couchage bon c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas la meilleure
saison pour se mettre au coin du feu vu
les températures mais l'hiver prochain
la cheminée se transformera en moque pas
de fumée pas dessus au plafond pas de
boire mais du bioéthanol comme preuve
c'est quelque chose qui est mobilisée
place n'est pas figé comme une cheminée
traditionnelle qui dépend du conduit qui
est au dessus ça reste l'immobilier qui
déplace à dire que demain on refait son
salon français cheminée on la déplace on
déménage on part avec côté jardin la
star de ce printemps c'est le barbecue
mais il lui manquait un meuble un bar en
teck circulaire pour les saucisses
partie très à la mode et des étais
vraiment long des arrières saison
agréable hausse or on utilise de plus en
plus la terrasse est de plus en plus
longtemps dans l'année et puis la foire
de paris c'est aussi le moment pour
certains exposants d'oser sortir leurs
plus beaux meubles si l'on peut dire
mais des goûts et des couleurs vous
savez bien on discute pas on en discute
pas à 35 ans il tire une révérence qui
pourrait être cette fois la dernière
fabien barthez a confirmé tout à l'heure
qu'il quittait le football club de
nantes
il se dit très choquée suite à une
altercation avec des supporters samedi
dernier son arrivée n'aura donc pas
permis de relancer le club manuel 6,6 et
fabien delory fabien barthez a quitté sa
maison de la banlieue nantaise avec
femme et enfants agressé par des
supporters de son propre club samedi
soir après une nouvelle défaite
barthez jette l'épongé il avait élu
domicile dans ce village en décembre
dernier pour sauver le fc nantes de la
relégation
il n'en est plus question non ça n'a
rien à voir avec avec le flou avec les
résultats parce que ce qui s'est passé
dépasse le cadre sportif
non non moi je ne sommes plus du tout en
sécurité là-bas donc à partir de là je
préfère je préfère partir
samedi soir fabien barthez a peut-être
disputé le dernier match de sa carrière
le champion du monde 98 n'a pu éviter la
descente aux enfers des nantais le 1er
avril ce but encaissé contre sedan et
son départ précipité avant la fin du
match avait creusé le fossé avec le
public
un tacle appuyé à l'entraînement avait
aussi tendu l'atmosphère avec ses
coéquipiers nantes va sans doute
descendre en ligue 2 après 44 ans dans
l'élite et barthez retourner à sa
retraite après quatre mois et demi de
galère et une image de l'ancien club de
fabien barthez marseille qui remonte à
la 4e place de la ligue 1 après sa
victoire 4 à 2 hier sur sochaux avec de
très beaux mou signé cana 6 et nasri ici
le dernier étant signée de
l'international franck ribéry qui fait
décidément un retour réussi le but
sochalien leroy et rodriguez contre son
camp on a appris cet après-midi la
disparition de grégory lemarchal le
jeune chanteur a succombé à
mucoviscidose d'une des maladies
génétiques
plus répandu en france et s'était fait
connaître en remportant la star academy
en 2004 il aurait eu 24 ans dans deux
semaines
voir
encore
que
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h45 fbi portés
disparus
à demain
tél